(slow rap music)
- Gary V.'s who you're working
for and what you're pursuing?
This video got widely spread in Taiwan.
If my mom is watching, why don't you?
It's awesome.
What are we talking about here?
- [Interviewer] So the
conference is called
World Business Experience.
- World Business Experience, WBE.
Gary V. coming to town,
WBE fucking September 19th.
I'm coming after you Hulk Hogan.
Okay, go ahead.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] September 27th, Warsaw.
- September 27th.
- Warsaw, outside of your
normal kind of promo hype.
They want just a quick
run down of who you are.
Just describe yourself.
- Understood.
World Business...
- [Interviewer] Experience.
- September...
- [Interviewer] 27th.
- [Person] They are recording.
- Poland, Warsaw.
Babbitt, you gotta use
that clip in the vlog.
I think people are gonna love it.
I think people are gonna
finally have that aah-ha moment
of like, "Oh, that's his content style.
"It's WWF 1987 promo videos."
What you think fucking JD, YD is here for?
Oh did we, did I send
you the, are they here?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] No.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yes, yes, yes.
I mean this is the entire
thing the vlog should be about.
This is the entire vlog right here.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
A dirty hillbilly Jim.
I gotta clean one.
All right, Corporal Kirchner.
Don't sleep on the corporal.
There we go, Corporal Kirchner.
Good shit.
Greg the fucking hammer Valentine.
Don't sleep.
The hammer will come down on you
super hard if you're sleeping.
Don't sleep on the hammer.
(laughing)
Do not sleep on the hammer.
Brutus the Barber Beefcake.
These two are tag-team
champions if you don't know.
Fucking Beefcake, baby.
Beefcake.
Brutus the Barber.
Terrible Terry Funk.
What you know about Terrible Terry Funk?
Nothing.
- Never heard of Terrible Terry Funk.
- It's because you are whack.
You are whack, if you don't
know who Terrible Terry Funk is.
Let's go, let's go.
The Hulkster, what you gonna do,
when the 24-inch pythons, come over here.
All right, Cowboy Bob Orton.
Cowboy Bob Orton is OG WrestleMania.
I don't know if people know
about Cowboy Bob enough.
SD Special Delivery Jones.
You guys don't know about SD Jones.
Lost the quickest match of
all time to King Kong Bundy.
If you don't know, now you know.
Paul Mr. Wonderful Orndorff.
Beast, his piledriver is still
grossly underestimated in his skill set.
Mr. Wonderful, another WrestleMania I OG.
King Kong fucking Bundy, boys.
I'm gonna put him with SD Jones.
This is the guy who beat him
in like fucking 10 seconds.
King Kong Bundy, another JYD.
Let's double it up, that's right.
You know who that is?
- I can't say, I don't know.
- Jimmy Superfly Snuka.
Come on, guys.
Superfly.
(laughing)
- What?
- [Interviewer] I'm sowing the memory...
I think it's your ...
I was a big wrestling fan
and know none of these guys.
- Dude, you know who this is, right?
- [Interviewer] No.
- Big John Studd, boys.
Big John Studd.
You know who this is.
- I don't.
- Fucking governor of Minnesota.
Jesse The Body Ventura.
- [Interviewer] Ventura.
- Let's go.
Come on.
You definitely know who this is.
- I don't.
- [Person] Is that Mr. Saito?
- Captain Lou Albano, you fucking idiots.
(laughing)
- [Person] You gotta
admit that it's Mr. Saito.
- Aww, man.
- [Person] That's my guy.
- You guys are super disappointing.
That's fucking, oh dude.
- That move was nice.
- That's Mick Foley.
Mick Foley, get outta here.
Oh, these are here?
- [Person] Yes.
- Oh my God, yes.
Sam Darnold T-shirts, baby.
This is fucking the best day ever.
Oh Quincy Enunwa.
These are fucking fresh.
These are fucking awesome.
- Look at this?
- And there it is.
What?
- What do we do?
- Yeah, yeah.
I'm in the rotation, promotion.
- [Person] Oh, got it, right.
- Poland, September 27th.
World Business Expo?
- [Interviewer] Experience.
- Poland, September 27th.
World Business Experience.
I'm giving the keynote.
My first time in Warsaw.
I know there's probably some of you
that don't know who I am.
I'm an entrepreneur, born in Belarus.
We're neighbors, came to the U.S.
Grew up very entrepreneurial,
lemonade stands,
baseball cards, always making a buck.
Making a couple thousand dollars
a weekend when I was a kid.
Eventually joined my dad's
liquor store business.
Took it from a three to a 60
million e-commerce business.
Became an early investor
in Facebook, Twitter,
and Tumblr, Uber, Snapchat, Pinterest.
Went on to build a very large,
global agency called VaynerMedia.
Five-time New York Times
best-selling author.
And arguably the greatest
keynote speaker of all time,
according to my mom and dad.
I'm going to bring the thunder,
I'm going to give you
the state of the union
of the opportunity.
The global nature of my
agency allows me to understand
what's happening in a Polish
and Eastern European market
from an influencer standpoint,
from a Facebook standpoint,
from a Twitter standpoint,
from a digital standpoint,
a Google standpoint, a blog standpoint,
a vlog standpoint, a YouTube standpoint,
a podcast standpoint.
I'm bringing standpoints, Poland.
Are you gonna join me?
(laughing)
- [Person] What's up?
- [Interviewer] Just like that.
- I think you should ...
Honestly, I think literally
from the first second.
- [Interviewer] That tells you.
- That's exactly what you
need to see. The whole thing.
Yeah, show that.
(slow rap music)